it's kind of interesting
i mean when i look at a new kind of
science you're now living inside the
history so you can't
tell the story of these decades but it
seems like the new kind of science
has not had the
revolutionary impact i would think
it uh might like it feels like at some
point
of course it might be but it feels at
some point people will return to that
book
and say there was something special here
this was
incredible what happened or do you think
that's already happened
oh yeah it's happened except that people
aren't you know
the sort of the heroism of it may not be
there but that what's happened is
for 300 years people basically said if
you want to make a model of things in
the world
mathematical equations are the best
place to go last 15 years
doesn't happen you know new models that
get made of things
most often are made with programs not
with equations
now you know was that sort of going to
happen anyway
was that a consequence of you know my
particular work in my particular book
it's hard to know for sure i mean i'm
always amazed at the amount of feedback
that i get from people where they say oh
by the way
you know i started doing this whole line
of research because i read your book
blah blah blah blah blah
it's like well can you tell that from
the academic literature you know whether
was there a chain of you know academic
references
probably not one of the interesting side
effects of publishing
in the way you did this tome is it
serves
as an education tool and an inspiration
to
[Music]
hundreds of thousands millions of people
but because it's not a single
it's not a chain of papers with spiffy
titles
it doesn't create a splash of citations
like it's had it's had plenty of
citations but it's it's you know i think
that the
it people think of it as probably more
you know conceptual inspiration than
uh than kind of a you know this is a
line from here to here to here in our
particular field
right i think that the you know the
thing which i am disappointed by
and which will eventually happen is this
kind of study of the
this sort of pure computationalism this
kind of study of the abstract behavior
of the computational universe
that should be a big thing that lots of
people do
you mean in mathematics purely almost
like it's like still mathematics
but it isn't mathematics but it isn't it
isn't it's it's a new kind of
mathematics is
is it an entitled book yeah right
why the book is called that right that's
not coincidental yeah
it's interesting that i haven't seen
really
rigorous investigation by thousands of
people this idea i mean
you look at your competition around rule
30. i mean that's fascinating
if if you can say something
right is there some aspect of this thing
that could be predicted
that's the fundamental question of
science that's the worst that has been a
question of science i think that's a
that is a some people's view of what
science is about
and it's not clear that's the right view
in fact as we as we live through this
pandemic full of predictions and so on
it's an interesting moment to be
pondering what what science's actual
role in those kinds of things is
oh you think it's possible that in
science
clean beautiful simple prediction may
not even be possible
in real systems that's the open right
question i don't think it's open i think
that question is answered and the answer
is no
well no no the answer could be just
humans are not smart enough yet
like we don't have the tools that's
that's the whole point i mean that's
that's sort of the big discovery
of this principle of computational
equivalence of mine and
um the uh you know this is something
which is kind of a follow-on to girdle's
theorem to
turing's work on the halting problem all
these kinds of things
that there is this fundamental
limitation
built into science this idea of
computational irreducibility
that says that you know even though you
may know the rules by which something
operates
that does not mean that you can readily
sort of
be smarter than it and jump ahead and
figure out what it's going to do
yes but do you think there's a hope for
pockets
of computational reducibility
computational re
reducible reducibility yes that's yes so
and then and then a set of tools and
mathematics that help you discover such
pockets
that's where we live is in the pockets
of reducibility right
that's why you know and this is one of
the things that have come out of this
physics project and actually something
that again
i should have realized many years ago
but didn't um
is uh you know the it it could very well
be that everything about the world is
computationally irreducible and
completely unpredictable
but you know in our experience of the
world
there is at least some amount of
prediction we can make and
that's because we have sort of chosen a
slice of um
probably talk about this in much more
detail but i mean we've kind of chosen a
slice of how to think about the universe
in which we can kind of sample a certain
amount of computational reducibility
and that's that's sort of where we where
we
exist um and uh it may not be the whole
story of how the universe
is but it is the part of the universe
that we care about
and we sort of operate in and that's you
know in science
that's been sort of a very special case
of that that is science has
chosen to talk a lot about places where
there is this computational reducibility
that it can
find you know the motion of the planets
can be more or less predicted
you know the uh uh something about the
weather is much harder to predict
something about you know other kinds of
things the the um
are much harder to predict and it's um
visa but science
has tended to you know concentrate
itself on places where
its methods have allowed successful
prediction
so you think rule 30 if we could linger
on it
because it's just such a beautiful
simple formulation of the
essential concept underlying all the
things we're talking about do you think
there's pockets of reduceability
inside rule 30 yes but it's a question
of how big are they
what will they allow you to say and so
on and that's
and figuring out where those pockets are
i mean in a sense that's the
that's sort of a uh you know that is an
essential
thing that one would like to do in
science um
but it's it's also the the important
thing to realize that that has not been
you know is is that science
if you just pick an arbitrary thing you
say what's the answer to this question
that question may not be one that has a
computationally reducible answer
that question if you if you choose
you know if you walk along the series of
questions and you've got one that's
reducible and you get to another one's
nearby and it's reducible too
if you stick to that kind of stick to
the land so to speak
yeah then you can go down this chain of
sort of reducible answerable things
but if you just say i'm just pick a
question at random i'm going to have my
computer pick a question at random
yeah most likely it's going to be
reducible most likely it will be
irreducible
and and what we're throwing in the world
so to speak
uh we you know when we engineer things
we tend to engineer things to sort of
keep in the zone of reducibility
when we're throwing things by the
natural world for example
not not at all certain that we will be
kept in this kind of zone of
reducibility
you